screams panic sirens victims lying on
the ground
bystanders shocked and confused as to
what to do to help the familiar
aftermath of a terrorist attack with a
vehicle weaponized to kill pedestrians
we've blurred the images of the
casualties but there were many it looks
as if some had been thrown into market
stalls by the force of the impact it
appears the white van may have traveled
several hundred meters along the city's
most popular thoroughfare before finally
coming to a halt any thought that this
could simply be a road traffic accident
ended with the sight of armed police
swarming through the area looking for
suspects it was late afternoon the
historic blasts ramblas district was
packed as usual with locals and tourists
the central strip is pedestrianised but
cars are permitted to travel either side
as the dead and injured lay where they'd
been hit those who had a narrow escape
tried to get to safety
all students heard the crashing noise
and the whole street to start to run I'm
screaming I saw a woman next to me
screaming for our kids police were very
very quickly there police officers with
guns bands everywhere and then a whole
street
so I getting pushback would see like
chaos at the top like just cars etc and
couldn't tell what happened then short
people who was running down this way the
police were pushed police officers of
God they just started screaming at
people to move back move back suddenly
just people started running towards us
screaming and shouting ran ran run so I
grabbed the two girls and there was an
orange phone shop was open we ran inside
and they locked the doors of the phone
shop police order nearby metro and train
stations to close it wasn't immediately
clear whether this was to avoid people
getting in the way of the emergency
response but then came word that one or
more suspects may be holed up in a
nearby bar the authorities confirmed it
was being treated as a terrorist
incident
I I spoke with police who were very
nervous and and training turrets away
saying that there's the a budget is on
the lose around here and that was
dangerous to today around Catalan police
say the death toll is expected to rise
in woods Sky News